[Music]
in second chance news submitted by sweet
teeth
oh sweet teas McDonald's you're sweet
he's pretty good oh thank you I haven't
made it in the wires they do taste like
big red gum because they give you the
surgery yeah nothing cuz I love them you
really meant it huh a woman who jumped
from a ferry in a personal euthanasia
attempt now savers a new lease on life
yeah so this woman this story is about
this woman her name is Maya de Ryan from
Canada and so 52 years old right oh
she's 52 what why she try to die so she
ended up being diagnosed a term with the
terminal illness and so her being
skeptical of Western medicine she opted
to not treat her illness and because she
said that she wanted to die on her own
terms what is it agent lady or what I
like that in like you're gonna say she's
skeptical of Western medicine so she
likes what southern medicine
northeastern bunch of [ __ ] magnets
and lay him on her body like that what
they do say is that she's an artist and
that she like it's very in tune with
like the universe and she's not a
religious person but she does believe
like in the greater you've explained
enough yeah I understand she's
interesting rollicking in the forest all
the time forms of medicine I feel like
Western would be the one that most
people would trust right depends because
there's a whole industry around it but
if I had cancer I will go east west
south north east okay I would do
everything in the [ __ ] world gimme
[ __ ] poopy tarragon roots or whatever
the [ __ ] I need I love people who are
like I believe in the universe it's like
bulnes said I mean yeah we know there's
a universe I can't even say that now cuz
in there's flat flat earthers that
believe in with our debts a meme they're
they're they're trolling yeah those
people are trolling their asses off dude
and I like I would love to say I'm a
flat earther like maybe I'll do that
maybe that'll be my news day because
only because it's such a trolli thing
you think there none of those guys are
serious you can
take a GoPro attached to a weather
balloon send it up and you'd be wrong
though because the GoPros a fisheye so
there are 32 more things to look like
this fear oh that's good you're good
you're very good okay what else do you
put it all the space what about all the
space photos they're all fabricated by
NASA and ago why I believe that to know
you can't see Mount Everest with the
telescope if it's all flat and you can
see any LA building with telescopes
because the government doesn't want you
to produce telescopes that can see that
far what's it got to do with the
government
oh the God use my own eyes and stand on
top of a building and not see downtown
LA why because the conspiracy is
everybody's trying to get booty
protruded booty picture did yep probed
mmm-hmm oh okay so she doesn't believe
in Western medicine and then she wanted
to die on her own terms
she told her adult son named Darby of
her wishes and he was really supportive
of her and so she ended up spending this
summer and the fall living with her son
which gave them a chance to say goodbye
and so the morning that she boarded the
ferry she left him a note that read
quote my body hurts my heart is full
it's time I love you Jo she posted a
video on Facebook that announced her
intention to die by skinny-dipping in
the ocean oh that's cold
yes it would not know how to swim she
was gonna freeze to death that's a
brutal way so as I mentioned before
she's an artist she made her living
using scales of dead fish to create
prints which is 1/8 ancient Japanese
form called art form called GOP otaku or
shukaku
cube that's that Japanese barbecue joint
do Kaku City Utah okay tapas fish
rubbing and so she wanted to she wanted
her death to be the ultimate expression
of her connection to the water gotcha so
she wanted a diver loves water
yeah so then like when she dies and then
she floats or like people find her and
they're that's this she thought I think
she thought that through
but so she got diagnosed in March right
spent the whole time with her son now on
October 30th is when she decided to jump
off the ferry that's the morning that
she left the note for her son mm-hmm she
calmly removed all her clothes and
jumped from the ferry do you picture
that the one calmly removing your
clothes and jumping off the side of the
ferry while you watch like that's weird
that guy seems from like the end of the
Titanic movie where they're still like
yeah she's just kind of yeah do you fold
your clothes if you're never gonna use
it again not you just thought or if
you're polite for the person who comes
and gets your horse yeah I think she was
buying mm-hmm that's true cuz there's
like i'ma jump to my death kind of take
off my clothes and there's like the hot
steamy sex leave the clothes all over
the floor kind of holy what's wrong yeah
she by that the trail yeah trail on the
way to the balcony right you see the
pants his trail up you see the bra
what's going on oh she's committing
suicide oh Jesus like a candlelit
[ __ ] bedroom yeah she left she did
she left a note on top of a pile of her
clothes stating that she had a terminal
illness and like why she jumped right so
she didn't realize that anyone saw her
jump but someone did and so they alerted
the authorities and that's when they
started doing a search for her
this search lasted five hours Wow
yeah she initially should try to swim
away from the ferry to avoid being
singing but regardless they still were
searching for her in the water and so
she watched the search expand and she
said that she was overcome with guilt
she was watching everyone look you just
there in the water like this like a
[ __ ] alligator like damn it just
[ __ ] up that frickin runs away in the
parents freak out and call the cops and
he sees everyone like [ __ ] looking
for him he's like alright he comes out
of the [ __ ] bushes and [ __ ] they're
pretty worried about me
berries a health and a helicopter
looking for her she just got really damn
cold at y'all's I big mistake she did
get really cold so she swam back no so
she was saying that she could feel the
intensity of the search and that crisis
and desperation to find her and she
didn't want to go in that way with that
negative negative energy as she couldn't
die in five hours
apparently not she didn't chop herself
or drown herself or something don't be
like if she was trying to end her life
right you would think you're trying to
end it like I don't tie a stone to your
ankles but then she was trying to spend
so those five hours could have been more
productive towards her goal rather than
just looking at the [ __ ] people like
intensifying the search
yeah like she did she thinks she'd get
all pruney and just wither away and
they're like yeah she was all into the
ocean it was a plan no it's my mom right
when she's like you got to get out of
theatre pruney
yeah [ __ ] she's saying that the first
few hours in the water she was laying on
her back backstroke in just like having
a go right she was meditating and doing
a breathing exercise in order to stay
buoyant and so she was said which this
part of my should stayed boy you should
try to dot it yeah and then this next
part to makes you ask the same question
which is the fact that she says that she
was focusing on keeping her core warm so
that the heat was so she still try to
survive aren't you chemically minded
dunno
pump your brakes bro come purebred tell
you what angry hey you pump yours too
all these like rescue teams looking for
her and she's just laying on her back
floating for five hours pretty much your
teaser out of the water I think she was
more like this I think her titties
rounded the water just to areola
sticking up on her stop thinking
thinking over Diddy's so then she's
saying that she beat eventually she
became so exhausted and tired now and
she lost her concentration and that she
started breathing heavily and that she
couldn't calm down and that she was she
started begging the universe to give her
a log or something to grab on
[Laughter]
[Music]
and so in that moment that's when the
glowing orange ring floated straight
toward her are you kidding me a
lifesaver yeah okay yeah and then so she
gave it to her then yeah she's I was
doubting that wasn't Allen the [ __ ]
search and rescue team it was a unified
universe tonight oh yeah in the
beginning of the story they do mention
that when she jumped and as she tried
something away that they saw she saw
someone throw like that orange ring in
the area where she jumped into the water
so like Mark where she jumped or
something maybe that's what it was
caused by anyway maybe so then uh oh so
then she think the universe conveniently
she's like universe key please give me
that ring that's floating towards me ah
thanks yeah right yes the the despite
the numbness that took over her entire
body she was able to grab on to the life
ring and then she says that she had to
make a conscious decision to let them
rescue her so she was loaded into an
ambulance rushed to the hospital into
ICU and then that's where a doctor's
work to stabilize her and prevent her
vital organs from shutting down because
by the time she was they got to her her
her body temperature was 31 degrees
Celsius which is which is of course it's
cold as hell in Canada 87 okay three
eighty seven point eight I think is a
matter for Greece eighty point seven
fair enough yeah doctors were just
really amazed at the fact that she
survived because they say that the
maximum survival time in the Pacific
Ocean which ranges from 7 to 14 degrees
Celsius is two to three hours and she
lasted five hours so she's not good I
died the fact that all this happened it
was like the universe telling her this
is not this is not your time war it's
just she's got really strong meditation
skills oh there's a lot of people that
could take pain if you know how to
meditate or she just has a really strong
connection with the water since she does
art with water and this fish scale that
sounds ridiculous as hell but she hasn't
dude what does that mean how does a
helper survive I have no idea I don't
know how it works I'm just saying is
that if she feel like she had a strong
bond with the water then the water was
like yo it's not your time to go I'm
gonna try to keep you alive right who
said about the strong bond with water
she said the universe Julie your
dedication your weird-ass religion is
pathetic I'm sorry is what she looks
like
so now she's just to the universe where
does it for her now to go back on her
Facebook and I was like hey guys in Ross
Tony I was trying to die yesterday say
yes that so the most shocking Musa ball
is the fact that the doctors told her
that her previous terminal diagnosis was
wrong a big up so she wasn't gonna die
and she throws it out of it she was in
perfect health
what how do you [ __ ] that up so all she
really needed this whole time was a
second opinion from another doctor he's
like looking at it upside down he's like
oh my god hurts upside down she's gonna
die holy [ __ ] you're definitely listen
ma'am you're definitely gonna die it's
terminal humpers in terminal yeah and
then six weeks later he's like looking
at me like oh oh my god wait holy [ __ ]
how do you [ __ ] that up you know what
though I've known uhm it's two different
groups of friends but like I known that
they've had people like family members
that were misdiagnosed of like having
cancer when they're perfectly by oh so
you always got to get a second opinion
to have ten no it happens all the time
I'm gonna get ten yeah I know I get a
second opinion I'm like this there's
those like they would talk about close
to me I Drive did the further one smart
man because I've had it bad on one one
there yeah I'm gonna have it bad
you gotta check them out you know got a
No
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]